6 30 on tuesday thanks for joining us
everyone i'm alex backus
i'm john langwood this morning we are
following breaking news a huge fire you
see on your screen there in the west
valley
yeah look at those flames it started
around midnight near tropicana and fort
apache it burned for several
hours our team has been following the
latest for you all morning long bianca
holmen keeping an eye on social media
has
incredible video from you the viewers
we're going to start with hector
here with a look at the investigation
hector good morning
good morning and right now it's too
early for firefighters to go through
that rubble and start looking into the
cause right now firefighters are still
working on hot spots
out here live you can see some of the
white smoke that's rising from that pile
of debris
right behind me this is where we're told
the fiery gutted more than 200
apartment units that were under
construction off in the distance we see
a building with several floors
the clark county fire department says
this was the eli
at ford apache project and it was
halfway done
they were pre-leasing for february of
this year according to their website so
a huge setback for that project
their cameras captured the earlier
larger flames this is directly behind
the crossroads plaza shopping center
close to businesses and homes by fort
apache and tropicana
we're told this is one of the biggest
fires for some of the crews out here at
one point this looked like an inferno
with flames appearing to shoot hundreds
of feet into the air
multiple departments came out here more
than a hundred firefighters from clark
county
las vegas north las vegas and henderson
thankfully though no injuries to report
this morning
and the high winds made things really
difficult for firefighters overnight we
know that some areas had
30 mile per hour wind gusts overnight
but again
no reports of injuries that's latest
from my vantage point our live team
coverage continues with bianca holmen
and bianca we heard the win last night
and made things really difficult and it
caused big concern for people in the
area
what can you tell us about that yeah
well hunter we're on the other side the
south side of this apartment complex
fire and as the sun begins to rise you
can
really see the damage from this side
they actually just stopped putting
water onto the flame to the smoke here
and to the embers that were still inside
the building
but there were evacuations in the area
because there are homes and apartments
in this area
police were going door to door telling
families to leave they were escorted to
a nearby middle school
for safety now this fire was so massive
that embers were flying as far south as
hacienda
firefighters were putting out small bush
and tree fires throughout the night
and these viewer pictures and video show
you just how high the flames got
they could be seen from the freeway and
also some other pictures show a
different angle you can see the
firefighters at work tearing through
fencing to try to control this blaze and
the pictures from gas stations that was
nearby there's several shopping centers
in the area
and it just shows you just how dangerous
this was to
nearby other potential things that could
catch on fire
and also video from people who woke up
nearby near
apartment complex and could see the
flames from their window
a pretty scary sight overnight now those
who were evacuated
they were able to get back into their
homes and we're also told that crews are
going to be returning to
nearby areas to check the property to
see if there were any damages
to nearby properties in the area
reporting live bianca holman 8 news now
send it back to you guys in the studio